حملات واسعه لاعتقال رجال دين سنه في
ايران بحجه تضليل الراي العام
واشنطن بالدفاع عن كوريا الجنوبيه
بالاسلحه التقليديه والرادعي النووي
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير قالت وزاره الدفاع في
بيلاروسيا ان تدريبات عسكريه مشتركه بدات
مع روسيا وتستمر اسبوعا وتشارك فيها
القياده المشتركه للقوات الاقليميه من
الجانبين وقالت الوزاره في بيان ان
التدريب هو جزء من الاستعداد لمناورات
عسكريه بين البلدين تجري في سبتمبر المقبل
في الاثناء افاد القائم باعمال رئيس
دونيتك دينيس بوشيلين بتقديم القوات
الروسيه او تقدم القوات رغم تعزيز المواقع
الاوكرانيه في المنشات الصناعيه في اول
دار وشيلين قال ايضا ان الاوضاع
الاوكرانيه الراهنه تزداد الصعوبه لان
الخسائر الفادحه في صفوفها لا يشكل اهميه
للقياده لاصدار الاوامر بالتراجع
في اليابان قال الامين العام لحلف شمال
الاطلسي يينز باك من قاعدتي روما الجويه
ان انتصار بوتين في حرب اوكرانيا سيرسل
رساله خطيره بانه يمكن تحقيق الهدف
باستخدام القوه العسكريه
لكنها سترسل ايضا رساله خطيره جدا الى
القاده في جميع انحاء العالم لان الرساله
بعد ذلك ستكون عندما يستخدمون القوه
العسكريه يمكنهم تحقيق اهدافهم
اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف 16 لمساعدتها في
التصدي للقوات الروسيه في ما لم يعطي بيضه
الصحفيين اي معلومات عن موعد زيارته
المتوقعه الى بولندا
اكيد الرئيس الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه
تتسع لانتقام من جديد من اوكرانيا كما
اعلن الرئيس سيليسكي بان جيشه يحضر الهجوم
المضاد الكبير ضد القوات الروسيه
وقد بداوا ذلك بالفعل اعتقد انهم لن
يكونوا قادرين على تحقيق اي مكاسب ايجابيه
لمجتمعهم وفيما يتعلق بجيشنا فانه سيقف
تقدم القوات الروسيه ويدمرها تدليجيا ونحن
نستعد لهجوم مضاد شامل
ومن المتوقع ان يلتقي وزير الخارجيه
المصري سامح شكري خلال زيارته الى موسكو
كلا من وزير خارجيه روسيا سيرجيو لافروب
ومسؤولين اخرين وقال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه ان الوزير شكري سيناقش مع
المسؤولين الروس مجبل ملفات العلاقات
الثنائيه بين البلدين وتبادل وجهات النظر
حول العديد من الملفات الدوليه والاقليميه
بما في ذلك تطورات الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وتداعياتها المختلفه
تصعدت حده تظاهرات المحتاجين في زاهدان في
ايران وصاحبها استنفارون امني وصفته حمله
الرشطاء البلوش بالاكثر التهابا واشتعالا
من اي وقت مضى ونفذت السلطات الايرانيه
حمله اعتقال واسعه لرجال الدين السنه على
اثري دعمهم الاحتجاجات والتي طالت رجلي
الدين مولاوي عبد المجيد مراد
والمولوي عبد الحميد اسماعيل زهيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وردد المحتجون شعارات مناوئه للنظام
الايراني وضد الفيل في طهران
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وايضا في طهران اطلق محتجون شعارات ليليه
في شارع شريعه ضد الحرس الثوري وضد الفسيد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ونشرت قناه ايران انترناشونال عبر صفحتها
على موقع تويتر ان 7 سجينات سياسيات
ايرانيات في سجن ايفين اعربنا في رساله
مفتوحه عن معارضتهم لاصدار احكام الاعدام
والتهديد بالقتل للسجناء في الحبس
الانفرادي
عقب استمرار ارتفاع اسعار المواد الغذائيه
في ايران خلال الشهر الماضي حضرت وسائل
الاعلام من ازمه سوء التغذيه في البلاد
كما توقع برلمانيون ايرانيون ارتفاع نسبه
التضخم الى 60% او اكثر في الاشهر المقبله
في ايران
احصاءات وزاره الصحه تظهر ان نحو 16% من
الاطفال دون سن السادسه في ايران يعانون
من سوء التغذيه
وان 800 الف طفل في سن النمو يواجهون نقصا
في الطاقه والمواد البروتينيه ونقصا في
المغذيات الدقيقه
برلمانيون توقعوا ارتفاع نسبه التضخم الى
اكثر من 60% بحلول مارس المقبل
مركز الاحصاء الايراني اكد ان معدل التضخم
السنوي في البلاد بلغ خلال الشهر الماضي
46.3%
خبراء اقتصاديون ونشطاء نقبيون قدروا ان
معدل التضخم الحقيقي في ايران اعلى بكثير
من احصاءات الحكومه
وخلال اقل من يومين تلقى الطيران ضربتين
احداهما على اراضيها في اصفهان واخرى على
الحدود العراقيه السوريه حيث استهدفت ثلاث
غارات قافله شاحنات يرجح انها محمله
بالاسلحه في منطقه واقعه تحت السيطره
ميليشياتها وذلك في دير الزور شرق سوريا
المزيد مع ليان الاختيار
بالرغم من تضارب المعلومات الذي يقال
لاعداد الشاحنات المستهدفه في البوكمال
ومحتواها لكن الاجماع يتمثل بضربه
اسرائيليه اخرى ساخنه لايران خلال اقل من
ثمان 48 ساعه حيث استهدف الطائرات مسيره
قافله شاحنات في منطقه واقعه تحت سيطره
الميليشيات الايرانيه في دير الزور شرقي
سوريا بعد عبورها من العراق ولم يتضح بعد
من يقف وراء هذا الهجوم العدد المرشع
المرشح للشاحنات المدمره هي ست شاحنات من
اصل 25 استهدفت بثلاث غراض بالمسيرات
والتي تقول مصادر سوريه انها اي الشاحنه
تحمل في الغالب
امداد من الشات ايران كون تاثير الانفجار
بعد الضربه كان كبيره القافله كانت قادمه
من ايران مرورا بالعراق وبحمايه المليشيات
المواليه لايران كاحزب الله العراقيه وفقا
للمصادر السوريه وعند توجه تلك القافله
الى سوريا وعبورها
ما هي الحدث الثوري وامليشيته هناك توقفت
الشاحنات في قريه الهري بالبكمال السوريه
وهناك تم استهدافها بالمسيرات واوضحت
المصادر ان الغاره الاولى كانت تحذيريه
لكن لم تصب اي شاحنه في ما استهدفت
الغارتان التاليتان تجمع تلك الشاحنات حيث
اصابت الصواريخ شاحنتين بشكل مباشر
واحترقت اربع شاحنات بشكل كامل وللتذكير
مشاهدينا معبر القائم يوصف بالممر
الايراني الذي يؤدي الى كل من لبنان
وسوريا يشهد كثافه عاليه بعمليات تهريب
الاسلحه وايضا البنيه التحذريه لانتاجها
وتجميعها على الاراضي اللبنانيه والسوريه
ورغم الاضرار التي لاحقت بم مسارات الممر
الجويه والبريه فهذه الضربات الجويه
المتكرره الا ان ايران لم تتخلى عنه
بتسهيل من ميليشيات الحجم وحزب الله
العراقيه من الجهه العراقيه طبعا وعلى
الجانب السوري تس التغطيه عشرات
الميليشيات التابعه للحارس الثوري والتي
تتخذ من البكمال ودرزور مركزا لها
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها
قبيله توجهه الى رام الله بل يمكن يلتقين
نظيره الاسرائيلي ويدعو للتهدئه في الضفه
الغربيه
احييكم من جديد قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ملتزمه بالدفاع عن كوريا الجنوبيه
باستخدام الاسلحه التقليديه
مؤكدا تعزيز المناورات العسكريه المشتركه
مع كوريا الجنوبيه وتسهيل التنسيق العسكري
الثلاثي ايضا مع اليابان اوستن قال ان
بلاده تعمل مع كوريا الجنوبيه على تعزيز
الحمايه مع كوريا الشماليه بالتزامني مع
تزايدي خطيرها ومن جانبه صرح وزير دفاع
كوريا الجنوبيه
على مراجعه استراتيجيه الحمايه من كوريا
الشماليه
يلتقي وزير الخارجيه الامريكي اليوم في
رام الله الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس في
اطار جولته بالشرق الاوسط تاتي زياره
بلنكن مع محاولات لخفض التصعيد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هذا وقد التقى بالانكن مع رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو حيث
اكد على ضروره اتخاذ الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين خطوات فوريه للحد من التصعيد
ووقفه مشددا على ان حال الدولتين مهم لامن
واستقرار المنطقه
في بشاور الى ثلاثه وتسعين
ارهابي
يتمكن من تجاوز الخطوط الامنيه والتسلل
لشرطه يضم مباني سكنيه وما قاره
يفجر نفسه واسط جموع المصلين في مسجد الحي
الرئيسي مخلفا عشرات القتل والجرحى جلهم
من عناصر الشرطه فيما وصلت فرق الانقاذ
عمليات رفع الانقاذ املا في العثور على
نجيب
والهلال الاحمر
ولا يزال هناك على الاقل شخصان على قيد
الحياه وربما عدد اخر من القتلى قد يستغرق
اخراجه من تحت الانقاد عده
حركه طالبان باكستان مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم
الا ان الهجوم الذي اعتبر الاكثر دمويه من
دون نحو عام عاد الى الاذهان مشاهد الدماء
والدمار التي شهدتها البلاد خلال العقدين
ودق ناقوس الخطر لدى كبار المسؤولين
السياسيين والعسكريين في وقت تعاني فيه
البلاد وانقساما سياسيا وازمه اقتصاديه
من بيوت الله واصابه العبارات
ونحن مستعدون للتضحيه لاجل ذلك
في وقت صعدت فيه جماعات ارهابيه وانفصاليه
هجماتها لعل من ابرزها حركه طالبان
باكستان التي اعلنت انسحابها من هدنه هشه
مع الحكومه شهره نوفمبر الماضي تزامن ذلك
مع شني اجهزه الامن عند تحملات امنيه
اسفرت عن مقتل واعتقال العشرات من
المسلحين
وترد الاوضاع الاقتصاديه يرى مراقبون انه
هجوم بشاور يطرح تساؤلات عده حول نجاعه
الاجراءات الامنيه ويجدد على ان الملف
الامني يظل من ابرز التحديات التي تواجهها
الحكومات الباكستانيه المتعقبه عبد الرحمن
العربيه بشاور
في الرباط عقد وزير الخارجيه المغربيه
ناصر بوريطه اول محادثات ثنائيه دبلوماسيه
مع عبد الله بتيلي رئيس بعثه الامم
المتحده للدعم في ليبيا
بعد اول لقاء مع عبد الله باتيلي رئيسي
بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا اعلن
ناصر بوريطه وزير الخارجيه المغربي ان
الامم المتحده هي التي يمكنها حصريا ايجاد
حل في ليبيا بعيدا عن التدخلات الاجنبيه
[موسيقى]
واحده ليبيا الوطنيه مع سيادتها الترابيه
في اطار سياده ليبيا وحدتها الترابيه
وحدتها الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
اسواقف نفسك
من مصلحه الليبيين الليبيون يعبرون عن هذا
بطريقه قويه ويريدون مؤسسات مستقره وذات
شرعيه تفتح الطريقه امام الازدهار في
بلدهم
على البقاء دائما على مسافه واحده من
الاطراف فيما ترى بعثه الامم المتحده
للدعم في ليبيا ان الشرعيه في هذا البلد
لا يمكن حلها الا عبر انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه بعثته الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا مع رئيسها الجديد تعتبر المغرب احد
الشركاء الدوليين في الملا في ليبيا فيما
الرباط ترى بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا مظله لما سارين اثنين يحتضنهما
المغرب حول الاز الليبيه مسارس خيرات
ومسار بوزنيقه عادل الزبير العربيه الرباط
على اسفل الشاشه حيث تقول تاز عن مسؤول
عسكري روسي الوضع في خاركيف صعب والقذف
مستور مستمر وانا القوات سيطرت على 25
منطقه في تركيا وعوده الى السياق نشرتنا
حيث تمارس الميليشيات الحوثيين انتهاكات
جسيمه بحق الاطفال في تعز ما تسبب باعاقات
دائمه للعشرات
بالعكازات هذه لا غير يتسابقان الى حيث
يلعب الاطفال لكنهما يعودان الى المنزل
خائبين دون ان تلامس الكره القدم احدهم
على هذا الحال يوميا وبوجه تملاه الحسره
يتجرع الطفل بدر وشقيقه قسوه الحياه منذ
ان بترت قدم بدر
في حي المطار القديم غربي المدينه
[موسيقى]
ولا اكتب ولا قرين
يمكن
اقسم
[موسيقى]
على الاسره نتيجه الحرب والحصان
اليمنيه التي تسكن الحيه
ايش بتقول بعطاش
بكل حاجه بمعنى
فاقرع بسبب الحوثي
من هناك من هذا الاقيهم بعدين ولهناء
يضربون قذائف ومجاز عن طريق ما يشوفونها
كثير من الاطفال يعني
التوقيت
فيها المعارك لكن استمرت جماعه الحوثي
بالسيداء في المدنيين والاطفال بشكل خاص
الاطفال النساء بالقذائف او عبد السلاح
القناصه عبر زراعه الالغام بكثير من
المديريه في تعز او كثير من المحافظات
اليمنيه
الميليشات الحوتيه انتهاكات الجسيمه بحق
الاطفال تشور احصائيه الى ان اكثر من 250
طفل في تعز يعانون من الاعاقه نتيجه الحرب
الحوثيه غالبيتهم لا يزالون يقطعون لجلسات
علاج طبيعي في مركز الاطراف الصناعيه
بمستشفى الثوره بتاعي عز
تعتذمه اذن الميليشيات الحوثيه ان تجعل
الكثير من ابناء المدينه هذه يعيشون في
اعاقه دائما خصوصا الاطفال والنساء الذين
تستهدفهم الى الاحياء السكنيه والطرقات
بالقضاء في والغام الارضيه ال سعيد
العربيه تعز في ختام النشره دوما نذكر
بالعناوين
بيلاروسيا تبدا تدريبات عسكريه مع روسيا
والاخيره تتحدث عن تقدم قواتها في اوبلده
حملات واسعه لاعتقال رجال دين سنه في
ايران بحجه تضليل الراي العام
واشنطن بالدفاع عن كوريا الجنوبيه
بالاسلحه التقليديه والرابع النووي
في امان الله
[موسيقى]